thank
[music]
you
thank
[music]
you
welcome back to another episode of
what's a proof hello Walter I'm Martin
we are doing some
news articles again
I see your titles are getting shorter
and shorter one of these days it's going
to be a two-letter word it's [laughter]
going to be an essay yeah
sarcastic with me
[laughter]
the reason why I did it like this is so
that we can know what it's all about yes
and it's also good for the internet then
they know what the buzzwords are great
okay but before we get into this we have
to ask the Lord for help that we can put
this together the way he wants it okay
all right heavenly father thank you for
being there for us every day and every
time that we can just lift up our heads
and
make everything known to you we ask that
you Enlighten us with a Holy Spirit and
that you guide through us through this
discussion in Jesus name amen amen
you know Martin the Bible says it's a
Time such as never was
now I'm an old goat but if you had told
me five years ago even five years ago
that isn't this and this and this would
all happen in the next five years I
would have said you know maybe 20 30 40
but not five most of the things
looks like we're living in a movie yes
we are in a movie
we are in a movie now I'm so glad
that we have this thing called time
because sooner or later it's going to
run out bruh [laughter] I can't wait for
the day we we don't have to ever watch
anymore we had a talk the other day at
Sabbath School
and the question was what is time
and there are scientists that say that
you know it's a figment of the
imagination
and others say you cannot Define it
and
I thought about it a little bit and I
thought what is time you know if if it's
so hard to Define what is it
and I've come to the conclusion that it
is an interpolation
in German you would say an einshoop
okay something that has been shoved in
that's it something that has been shoved
in shoved into what shoved into eternity
yes so you had this dimension of
Eternity
and then you had this interpolation this
einshup this shove in this wedge
called time
so in other words God created time
and then he he created the planet with
uh moon and stars and sun
two set times and seasons
obviously there must be a purpose why
there should be time why there should be
this interpolation and obviously the
only solution to that is
it's to deal with the sin question
exactly you can't have a sin question in
eternity because that would be Eternal
misery so you have to have iron Shoop
you have to have an interpolation you
have to say Okay I'm going to interrupt
eternity with a thing called time and
then I'll write a book about it this is
the book Martin
and I'm going to tell you exactly what's
going to happen in this interpolation in
this time in this time slot and if you
don't believe me
then check after the event has taken
place because God says see I tell you
ahead of time so that when it does
happen you will believe and then it
tells you what it's going to be like and
it tells you in in Matthew what it's
going to be like and then he tells you
in Daniel ahead of time what the
political situation and the religious
situation is going to be and then he
tells you in the Book of Revelation
exactly what is going to happen and then
people will still not believe yeah
[laughter] so what's the point
but thank God not all it is for those
that will believe okay so there will be
a Seed of Abraham
that will have faith and will believe
because after all he told you ahead of
time
but some some of the things it tells you
ahead of time are so improbable that you
think they will not happen but here that
happened and it's happening and a lot of
people don't like to hear that we're
almost at the end of time I cannot wait
I'm so glad the longer your titles get
Martin it's going to be the better it is
for us it's going to be like you said
essays pretty soon
okay and you know what's the sad part
this is I couldn't even fit everything
in here what
[laughter]
all right so basically the longer the
title gets the more uh prophetic
fulfillment we have it's all linked to
perfect fulfillment okay so this is what
we're all talking about
so a time of trouble such as never was
so and if it was never like that before
it must be pretty bad in other words
everything that is practiced everywhere
all over the world I'm talking about the
evil one
he's going to throw the book at us yep
he's got his book of notes and that's
more than an essay long and he's going
to throw it at the world I think he's
busy I can see it and feel it and we're
not even talking about some of the
issues right
so you've titled that cyber attacks grid
failures climate religion gender war and
religious upheaval and again these are
just events that's it
don't get sucked into one of these
exactly these are just events look at
the events but always bear in mind
where's it heading
and the greater the events and the more
cumulative they become the more likely
it is that people will shout enough
already let's get a solution and the
solution is ha Peace at Last and then
you have destruction chaos
that's basically it why should we
continue and show all this stuff no we
can let it play and we can leave okay
all right see you next time
[laughter]
all right let's have a look at what
they're saying
New York Post 400
000 gallons of radioactive water leaked
from Minnesota nuclear plant at least
400 000 gallons of radioactive water
leaked from a Minnesota nuclear
power plant in November
but officials only published publicly
revealed the spill on Thursday
so they're keeping a lot of this stuff
harsh it's amazing that's why I put in a
few of these
usually it will be all over the news
when something like this happens but now
this more and more things happening that
are disturbing
but it isn't brought to the attention of
the people all right here's a thought
Martin
the spirit of Prophecy says
that calamities will increase there will
be fires there will be storms there will
be uh collisions and calamities on the
great lines of travel
ships will go down trains will crash
airplanes she never spoke about those
but the great lines of travel include
airplanes will crash
and you know technology has come to a
point where none of this should actually
happen it should be so organized that
Trends should never Collide I mean they
have senses to tell you when the train
gets a wobble they should be able to
break and stop and all of these things
but then if that system breaks down or
you have a Cyber attack couldn't you
have calamities like you who have never
imagined Could Happen absolutely it will
be a very very dark day when all of that
happens yes and recently when they shut
down all flights in the United States
because there was a hiccup in the system
imagine if that hiccup takes place while
everything's in the air well could be it
could be interesting right there's a lot
of things that can cause huge problems
and it's very probable that it can
happen Okay and then Humanity thinks all
right we'll solve the problem with a i
and a I will keep everything on the
level and then a i goes Rogue and then
you really have a Calamity exactly so it
could become a very interesting age such
as never was you know what and I must
I'll just say it bluntly I think this is
upon us it's not in the far distant
future anymore all right now what if
some of it is even fact just to create
fear I think a lot of it will be fake
but unfortunately some of it will be
real and it still doesn't matter because
the outcome will be the same right now
whether it is the devil doing it or
whether it is the destroying angel that
does it the outcome is the same same all
right
so we have these calamities so while the
Energy company reported the leak of
water containing tritium
to state and federal authorities and the
nuclear Regulatory Commission Lost full
State officials said they waited to tell
the public until they had more
information
how much information do you want before
you warn people that they are exposed to
radioactivity yeah that's why I think it
can be put another way they'd rather
wanted to keep silent to see if it can
go away
hmm
so they had to decide what to do with
this contaminated groundwater how much
leaked into the ground before sharing
the information
and then Martin you had this terrible
[snorts]
train smash now I know it's been
reported on a lot and people have spoken
about it and the interesting thing is
that the very events that took place are
pretty disastrous number one yeah
but almost like biblical prophecy they
were foretold in Jesuit theater
and the thing is what happened here is
it seems that there's no urgency to do
the cleanup or just get people to safety
it seems as though almost like they want
a Calamity that's the same with the
previous slide of the nuclear waste it's
almost as if they want Calamity to
start happening okay
all right let's have a look at the news
and then we'll look at some other
interesting information
the Train derailed on February 3rd at
[music] 8 54 pm
it was carrying 20 cars of hazardous
materials including vinyl chloride a
highly [music] flammable toxic gas that
causes central nervous system problems
and has been linked to a host of cancers
[music] in
the days after the accident Norfolk
Southern worried the vinyl chloride
could explode [music] so they did a
controlled burn potentially releasing
phosgene a gas used as a chemical
warfare agent in World War One videos
soon spread widely from residents
[music] who were afraid and unsure of
what they'd been exposed to it still
smells like a chlorine
and then please like a bad taste in your
throat many reported rashes sore [music]
throats nausea headaches and respiratory
problems as well as seeing sick animals
and water covered in a chemical Sheen
there's no way that's safe
they're
calling [music] it The Airborne Toxic
Event they won't come this way will we
have to leave our home of course not how
do you know I just know okay what if
it's dangerous
that white noise movie is fascinating
isn't it
can you believe how similar even the
footage is absolutely now what's
fascinating Martin is
those chemicals I mean they are
chemicals that were used in chemical
warfare right
and they're being transported by Mega
corporations and companies that own
these things that have their fingers in
virtually every pie that you can imagine
and when you look at the way in which
they reacted and how casual the
government official was exactly let's
not say too much about him except that
he had strange shoes on
[laughter]
and
this this is very interesting and that
there are movies and these companies are
all Affiliated and associated with the
Vatican
deeply deeply and will in a later video
show also how they this same company or
companies have got their fingers in the
Ukraine situation yes absolutely this is
so fascinating so it could just be an
accident
but it was foretold with such accuracy
that one one is interested and and just
the the connections who owns what yeah
and how it was done is interesting to
say that let's just leave it there let's
leave it there but I was just thinking
you know what did you start off with
telling us that time
God showed us in the Bible ahead of time
what's going to happen now isn't it
interesting that maybe the adversary is
trying to do the same but through movies
yes because that's his mouthpiece he
doesn't have a word it doesn't have
that's his mouthpiece yes yes so the
movies the Jesuit theater is his
mouthpiece
now imagine if you jump from an accident
in the United States of America and you
jump to our part of the world which is
as far away as you can possibly get
then we are expecting food and water
shortages
now what's interesting is that it's not
on our news it comes from the United
States that is warning its citizens in
the country
so I think let's go and do a campaign in
Namibia [laughter]
for a little while yeah okay the United
States government has warned its
citizens in South Africa to stockpile
three days worth of supplies including
non-perishable food
three liters of drinking water per day
and medicine and first aid supplies
in addition to stockpiling food and
water the embassy offered the following
guidance have a Communications plan for
when there is no or limited power cell
phone battery additional charging cords
how are we going to get what's a profit
when all this crashes
believe that to God right exactly
all right ensure that you have the
necessary medicines memorize family
members phone numbers identify safe
areas store flashlights batteries Etc
and this comes from the U.S embassy
interesting
and this comes from the embassy so the
embassy advisory comes after the U.S
government told businesses and financial
institutions operating in South Africa
to start thinking about a total grid
collapse
well Martin we are expecting a total
grid collapse in this country and I'm
always surprised when I read overseas a
tornado went through and you know 100
000 people were without power that's
world news and down for how long Yeah in
our country the whole country is without
power exactly every day and if you take
Zimbabwe it's half the day every day
that there are without power you cannot
run an industry like that we're off
Alpha day yes at this stage yes we are
in stage four six again yes so we can
expect the great excitement and how many
promises were made that it will never
happen well many promises there's many
promises
and then in the UK there's a rationing
of vegetable and it's about
normalization so now they bring In what
climate change climate change you know
we've we've had too many things modern
we have to hone down it's not a bad
concept really to hone down why should
they said at one stage they said why
should you have so many choices of
cheeses when two or three would be quite
adequate well that sounds a little bit
Marxist to me
the past few days have seen certain
fruits and vegetables rationed by Major
UK
supermarkets Aldi Morrisons Tesco
Sainsbury's all of these I think we've
shared this before but just to show that
it's as a result of pandemics breakdown
of supply routes farming
infrastructure not enough fertilizer and
it's just ration yeah well the
interesting interesting is now they want
to give brexit also
the blame yes why not blame brexit
but uh the other side of the brexit
devices firmly set on blaming any
shortage on the weather so it's climate
change or political change which one is
it Martin or is it both planning or is
it planned I think it's planned okay so
the real reason there are shortages
supposing there are real shortages you
see even they are skeptical here not
just sigh of nonsense like the toilet
paper Fiasco at the beginning of the
pandemic is that one way or another
there have been engineered
so Martin this is not a conspiracy this
is just an observation
that's a good a good point
and then we have World War
two-style rationing of food fuel needed
to combat climate change academics claim
in new paper this is Fox News from
this year so Martin
are they preparing Humanity for
something yeah conditioning isn't this
called conditioning definitely and then
afterwards there comes coercion all
right and it's researchers at the
University of Leeds so these are
peer-reviewed articles that tell you
that these things are going to happen
a top British institution wrote in the
journal ethics now I don't need a
peer-reviewed article to tell me that
there will be famines no I can have a I
can just read Matthew 24 and it'll tell
me that and I don't have to wait for
confirmation from a peer-reviewed okay
so there's a difference that one gives
the wrong blame
they want to give a blame to something
else ah okay the Bible talks about a
total decay of moral values
and they talk about climate change
so the problem of course is policy and
environment that rationing has been
wrongfully neglected as a policy option
for mitigating climate change arguing
such an approach would be more effective
than the slow inequitable result from
tax side to promote a green agenda so
Martin are they pressed for time to
bring it in rapidly yes there's no time
to hike the taxes and make people
tighten the belt let's just bring in
World War II rationing finished and I
think the thing is they've tried it for
so it's not going as quick as they
wanted to that's why it's going to this
so let's go that way
so Martin what vehicle could be used to
accelerate things cyber attacks aha
let's have a look
hello and welcome let's take a look at
our top story this hour the UK
organizations experienced an average of
788 weekly cyber attacks across 2022
this marks a 77 increase from the year
2021. now the new figures reveal the
growing concerns of cyber threats the
increase in cyber attacks is largely
driven by sophisticated ransomware gangs
stock trading in London was plunged into
chaos after reports of a russia-backed
ransomware gang attacking a company that
plays a key role in Britain's Financial
system
the group behind the Cyber attack
against Royal Mail last month targeted
trading software provider ion group on
Tuesday
the london-based company plays an
integral role in the plumbing that
underpins the trading of shares date and
derivatives in the square mile I'll say
that 42 clients have been affected by
the attack as it faced disruption in its
clear derivatives division
the attack comes just weeks after
Lockwood forced Royal Mail to suspend
International postage deliveries now
this left more than half a million
Parcels letters stuck in limbo earlier
on the 11th of January the guardian
confirmed that it was hit by a
ransomware attack and that the personal
data of UK staff members had been
accessed in the incident now these are
not Standalone incidents rather these
vindicate the precarious condition of
cyber security in businesses across the
United Kingdom
according to a UK government report
published last year almost every one in
three businesses in the UK are
experiencing data breaches or cyber
attacks at least once a week now this
constitutes 31 of all businesses and
over a quarter of Charities are
suffering
the report shows that cyber attacks are
becoming more frequent with
organizations reporting more breaches
over the last 12 months this is from
National Review
for the second time in a few weeks
listen to this a federal law enforcement
agency suffered a serious Cyber attack
and the U.S Department of Health and
Human Services warned that
russian-linked ransomware group called
klopp had reportedly taken
responsibility for the Mass Attack on
more than 130 organizations including
the health care industry ransomware
attacks are now common as rain storms in
a busy news cycle you might not have
heard but two federal law enforcement
agencies have had serious cyber attacks
this last month the government system
that sends messages to Pilots called No
Tam had gone down
and then the emergency backup system had
also gone down now the FAA claimed it
first noticed this on Tuesday night when
the problem could not be fixed the
government issued a ground stop the next
morning
that's what people the judge said he
described the culprit here as quote a
damaged database file with no evidence
of a Cyber attack
so to repeat said people to judge there
was no evidence of a Cyber attack and
then the next day last Thursday we
noticed that virtually the same thing
happened in Canada
well that was very strange because the
U.S and Canada have separate Aviation
authorities they're different countries
and each country uses its own software
to Route their planes the systems are
not linked to each other
and then we remembered that on New
Year's Day two weeks ago something
similar happened in the Philippines its
air traffic control system also went
down
for a time no aircraft were allowed in
Philippine airspace thousands of flights
over Asia had to be rerouted in the
summer of 2020 UCSF medical school paid
more than a million dollars in Bitcoin
and they paid it in order to get access
to their own computers which had been
frozen by hackers they were held up for
ransom since the Nationwide ground stop
last Thursday the price of Bitcoin has
shot up
about 20 percent
is that a coincidence
well Martin that's all very interesting
now the idea of course of taka here is
that
the Bitcoin shot up because it was used
to pay ransoms it's a currency of choice
for those that require ransoms
it's a very interesting time that we are
living in but how many companies one in
three one or three every day it's the
statistics is is actually
scary
because
these type of things can lead
to what we've heard the old time
speaking about great failures
all of these things didn't Cloud swap
say that this was going to happen
so you have to be prepared you have a
lot of little ones and then you can have
a big one so be prepared
all right and we we spoke in the
beginning about uh the adversaries
medium to warn people and to desensitize
them and to inform them
and this film icon Dennis Quaid has
captivated audiences with this kind of
thing it's interesting that in this
video it says Great Balls of Fire does
that remind you of a vision in the
spirit of Prophecy yes or Nashville
Nashville and pillar of the pillar was
struck and all of these interesting
things and of course that perfect
replica of the Parthenon that is there
consists of many pillars and they put in
that stature we spoke about all of those
things but Hollywood is always a step
ahead yeah now so they again
desensitizing you or getting you ready
for what is probably about to come yes
and Simpsons and all of those those are
the prophetic mouthpieces of what is
being planned
while the two adversaries sit at the
same table
but Dennis Quaid's now done something
that nobody's ever been able to do
scare the heck out of Jesse Waters
Kuwait has a new documentary out grid
down power up which explores the
frightening possibility of our energies
grid going down
heat gas for our cars transportation for
food restocking all of it relies [music]
to some extent on electricity
but no one likes to focus on what could
happen if it all suddenly is taken away
a
[music]
nuclear explosion in the atmosphere
above the United States could unleash
[music] a burst of invisible electrical
energy that within a fraction of a
second
wash [music] over this country and
overload all of our most sensitive
electronic devices
including
the nation's power grid just
30 days without electricity it would
take us back to 1880 and you wouldn't be
able to get gas you wouldn't be able to
get food you know the police would stay
home take care of their own families and
be we'd be there are plans for
hurricanes there are plans for
snowstorms there are [music] plans for
earthquakes there is no plan for a Cyber
attack that would be infinitely longer
in [music] duration and more widespread
than any of those natural disasters this
is something that if it does happen
um
it's going to make the the covid look
like a kid's show wow
well Martin that's nothing new our other
Prophet Klaus Schwab already said that
and isn't it interesting that they have
the same rhetoric the same story it's
just part of the scenario
now the scary thing is this probably can
happen
yes let's say it probably will happen I
think so so let's have a look in South
Africa
well that's why in South Africa they
sent out a letter all the insurance
companies to their clients you received
one and I received one let's just show
what it says it says important
information regarding your cover
the instability of South Africa's power
supply especially in recent times has
become a major concern across all
sectors including the insurance industry
it has become clear that the risk of a
potential grid failure can no longer be
ignored one of the core principles of
insurance is that the insured event
should involve some amount of
uncertainty grit failure can now no
longer be considered uncertain or
entirely unforeseeable and this combined
with the consideration that such as the
insurance Market has prompted us to
reinforce and clarify the cover provided
for losses resulting from grid failure
in its policy terms and conditions
yes so basically what also happened if
you read it further in the document
they're not going to cover any loss for
grit failure and that's from the 1st of
April so we're right there now Martin
we're not covered anymore for grid
failure
and you know with us it's apparently
let's just say apparently infrastructure
collapse
but overseas a Cyber attack will do it
as well
so once again
however it happens the outcome is the
same the outcome is exactly the same
well isn't here's an interesting one by
King David's studio and uh I understand
this gentleman is an Adventist that's
what I've heard well let's see what he
has to say a catastrophe that we we
speak of uh is total darkness yes yes is
total darkness a possibility absolutely
it's imminent it's not even a
possibility it's it's dominant yeah it's
a minute
listen but it's equally avoidable
obviously 100 yeah but at the rate this
train is going
it doesn't look like we're going to
avoid it yeah I mean right now the
analogy I would give is that we are all
passengers in a breakless bus that is
driven by
the board of escom the management the
government
and but we are going towards the cliff
that's a problem can we confidently in
this conversation say we are probably in
our lifetime you and I going to
experience total darkness this is some
point you're saying this year yes yes
not even in our life
what is what is total darkness in your
definition
nothing works nothing at all nothing you
can't transact
the banking system is down the Telecom
communication system is down banking is
telecommunication by the way so the
telecommunication system is completely
down the
water reticulation of course is
completely gone yeah fuel transportation
by pipeline is completely gone gas
Transportation uh sewer treatment and
Sewer you know removal completely it
stops uh you can't bury you have to bury
the people if they die on that day
immediately yes immediately because then
there is no backup there is no fuel no
one can move anywhere there's no food
you can buy there's processing of food
the farmer hasn't got anything the the
the the losses of all the fresh produce
that currently is in any one place
within a matter of two days all of it is
gone fraught
and you're talking about uh you know the
the meat industry which is the key
source of protein for many people rather
talking about chicken beef or anything
else everything else
hospitals there is no hospital you can
go to there's no health care you can be
able to access there is no even the
president will not have fuel for the
helicopter to run anywhere
now Martin these were people in the know
these are not just any people
and he paints a pretty bleak picture and
he foresees that it could happen this
year already
and it sounds like a Time such as never
was
imagine you take a modern society and
you in a day dump it into the Middle
Ages yeah that is pretty chaotic you
know there's many people that don't know
how it feels to be able to walk to a
door and there's a light switch on next
to it and you just put it on
there's many people that don't know how
it feels not to have that privilege yes
well we have been warned at the Times
such as this would come and we have been
told get out of the Cities because
that's where the chaos will be the
greatest
because there's no way of growing food
and receiving supplies in those
circumstances
so you know the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy
they have warned us and we had better
take it
now there are circumstances like like we
we are going to do a Camp Meeting In
Another Country what if you're trapped
there well that's God's problems yes but
let us be found doing our work when the
Lord comes and let us have faith and let
us act on his warnings
because here we have
a promise even from the Dark Side that
these things will happen
how much more so should we heed what
comes from the Light Side that's so true
we've got like we've mentioned Hollywood
the prophet of the enemy
telling us this is going to happen and
we had God the true Prophet telling us
imagine what is very important that we
should understand it when you study the
prophecies in the Bible
they're linked to Disobedience and moral
decline
when you look at the reasons that the
enemy gives
they're totally different yeah
in fact sin becomes so Paramount and so
invasive but it's never the fault of sin
it's always the fault of climate or some
action or something of that nature
so here we have a very interesting
Double Take Martin
the Catholic church is very involved in
pushing The Narrative of climate change
but here you had a cardinal George Pell
who was not so convinced and actually
spoke out against it
and you're not Martin when when someone
has a voice which goes against the Roman
Catholic narrative it's always
interesting to watch what happens to
them yeah look at the news and are they
still active today have they been
removed from society was it natural
wasn't it natural were there accusations
you know I don't believe anything
anymore basically that comes out of the
media you have to read between the lines
yeah certain you have to weigh up it's
like reading the Bible if you take it
out of context you can you get something
totally different so let's see what he
had to say he saw climate science as a
dangerous religious Dogma
in the end his Hardline stance helped
the church back the late Cardinal George
Pell left the legacy of climate science
denial which in his later years became
even more distance from reality and the
position of the Catholic church for
decades in newspaper columns and
speeches
Pell popularized climate denial talking
points to dismiss the science of global
Heating and to Brand environmentalists
as hysterical and in the grip of
pseudo-religion
well that voice is gone and it's in the
narrative continues yeah and it's
interesting how they downplay how they
make him oh he's actually distant from
reality
the news agencies always if you are on
this they want to link it if you are
climate climate change denial
they want to link it to a mental problem
yes then you are mentally
diseased
and obviously if you are on the same
bandwagon even if you have zero
education in a particular direction then
you receive a honorary doctorate like
Greta turnberg so we've gone from the
sublime to the ridiculous but not in
anything in theology yes exactly why
theology what's climate change going to
do with theology that's the interesting
link it's a pseudo-real religion like
Powell said actually yes so it was quite
right so the Swedish climate activist
Greta tenberg is awarded an honorary
doctorate from the theology faculty of
the University of Helsinki and the
reason why she receives the award is
that she has given us all a task that
extends beyond our everyday choices
through her action The Faculty explains
now Martin this is so ludicrous that one
wonders whether the people that decide
these things are still in charge of all
their faculties
[laughter]
yeah well put you see I know it is
ludicrous but we've got a problem like
we've always said this is reality these
people are making
policies according to what according
to this now interesting Martin even if
you are selling a lie if you're short
enough and carry on enough there it
seems like the majority goes with the
LIE they follow suit they just follow
suit so well let's leave it at that I
really don't think we should actually
read on but you think we should right
just a little bit more all right let's
read on a little bit more just to get
riled up
it is not about the combination of faith
and climate but about the link between
tunberg's climate activism and science
as faculty we agree with the fundamental
goals she propagates at the same time
climate activism connects to theology in
some sense
who is an expert in Old Testament
studies adds the Earth is God's creation
and we care for it there are already
some texts in the Old Testament for
example in the prophets that deal with
climate change many things have changed
since the Bible was written but much is
the same humans are the same God is the
same the Earth is the same only the
concerns are more severe
it is not the first time turnback has
received an honorary doctorate the
Belgian University of batigan awarded
her in 2019 so she is accumulating them
can you believe it yes but this is very
interesting so the Bible is all about
climate change you see where they now
this links on to where we will go next
the gender problem
is also what do they do with the Bible
here in the climate thing yes turns it
upside upside down and let's turn the
gender thing upside down as well
and human have always been the same
humans are the same
so there's no decline everything is the
same everything has been this is
uniformitarianism they should all become
geologists and not theologists yeah that
will probably work
now seeing that Greta is such Authority
on the issue at the latest Davos
she was asked a few questions so let's
have a look how serious she was right
credit how many times did you rehearse
your arrest at the German coal mine so
the police starts to bring the first
person to the identity chain
okay
it's very likely that the German police
and rwa fossil fuel company would stage
how [laughter]
many how many times did you were you
arrested because you posed for several
times didn't you sure
what if you want to end fossil fuels how
did you get to Davos today
came yesterday I didn't came today how
did you travel here uh several trains
civil trains or planes
I took a private jet of course took a
private jet yes
I mean you laugh about this but surely
if it's such a big issue it's surely no
laughing matter I mean this is an
opportunity for you to try and get
people who don't agree with your message
to try and see it from your side of the
side of the view and to maybe change
their ways surely
yeah I wish I could tell that to me
myself sometimes to take things more
seriously but you know I'm just
a young person I I
tend to laugh at most things
all right seeing that she got a
theological degree
we now have confirmation by the
theologians that climate change is a
theology
that it is a faith that's it they have
confirmed it for us very kindly
and let's see how far this is going when
it comes to other sectors like the
United States and Joe Biden's ideas do
we have a redefining of sin
yes
which one of the Ten Commandments deals
exactly with climate change
not one of them oh all right so if that
was the definition of sin in the Bible
we need a new one
and we we saw that they wrote them on
table tables of stone so obviously they
do think that the climate issues are the
new sins
and the pope is fully behind it but then
he's always been behind changing the law
it says that's his Forte he's very
involved in that it's interesting like
you mentioned now so Greta and the
theology honorary degree that she's just
received or doctorate and this proves
that this is actually a religion so in
this religion has to have rules yes all
religions have rules let's have a look
that's what climate change is about it
is literally not figuratively a clear
and present danger
the health of our citizens and our
communities is literally at stake the
un's leading international climate
scientists call the latest climate
report nothing less than quote code red
for Humanity let me say it again code
read for Humanity and making the largest
investment ever 2.3 billion dollars to
help communities across the country
build infrastructure that's designed to
withstand the full range of disasters
we've been seeing to up to today extreme
heat drought flooding hurricanes
tornadoes consistent with the
president's executive order on tackling
the climate crisis at home and abroad we
are issuing a comprehensive
environmental justice enforcement
strategy communities of color indigenous
communities and low-income communities
often bear the brunt of the harm caused
by environmental crime pollution and
climate change
so of course there's no science or data
behind any of those claims they're
political slogans they're completely
made up they're not real
but it's happening anyway so we're
directing natural disaster Aid on the
basis of skin color jacket decades ago
it used to be one or two a season would
happen now with climate change in these
extreme warm Waters it's almost you know
it's happening all the time this storm
in a way is kind of bad news for the
people that are still trying to deny
climate change as a factor Florida
Republicans deny climate change as a
monster storm barrels towards the coast
this will be a first time test uh for
how you adapt to these new stronger
storms on a warmer Planet as a result of
climate change the threat exacerbated of
course by climate change Charleston like
Miami gets water that comes up on a good
sunny day that's climate change because
water levels are rising our Earth is
getting warmer and there is just no
doubt I think left that it is feeding
these beasts turns out people keep track
of hurricanes
there are lists of hurricanes so we know
there has been no increase no increase
in Hurricane frequency in the United
States from 1900 to 2020 120 years in
fact the number of hurricanes actually
declined over the last century and in
that same period deaths from hurricanes
other natural disasters have dropped by
90 percent
20 years ago before he died Michael
Crichton delivered a talk in San
Francisco about the climate crisis and
he described climate activism in that
speech as the religion not a political
movement a religion for urban atheists
for people who rejected every aspect of
Judaism and Christianity
climate activists had
without saying so out loud created a
religion all the features you would
recognize in any conventional religion
they had their Eden which would be the
world before the settlers arrived they
would have their
original sin because every religion has
that in their case it would be the
Industrial Revolution
and because of that original sin they
believed a Rapture was coming an end of
times and in their telling the end of
times was climate catastrophe
so the only way to save yourself from
this Rapture from this end of times was
to renounce your energy sins and embrace
climate activism
so Crichton identified this as a sign
that religious beliefs are inherent
everyone has them even atheists you may
not worship God but You're Gonna Worship
something and that's true
thousands of protesters took to the
streets of Oxford to express their
opposition to the wef's 15-minute City
agenda
drivers will have to obtain government
passes to travel through certain areas
and if they exceed their ration limit
networks of license plates scanning
surveillance cameras will zap them with
fines Council calls it traffic calming
but it looks an awful lot like a de
facto climate lockdown and population
control
I could stand here and say more or less
what other people are going to say about
the effect of these 15-minute
neighborhoods soon to become digital ID
facial recognition zones
let's say my friend lives in Zone 3 and
I'm in zone one if for example I went to
my friend's house in Zone 3 my parents
normally come and pick me up in their
car it only takes 10 minutes
so does that mean that they would have
to go round the Ring Road and back into
town again
if my mum or dad had to drive around the
Ring Road it would take 30 minutes
causing much more pollution and leaving
a much bigger carbon foot they will say
you can walk home would that be safe for
me to walk home me as a 12 year old
walking home in the dark alone is that
really going to be safe then they will
say oh don't worry about that we've
already thought of that you'll be safe
we will have a thousand cameras on the
streets following you and tracking you
all the way home oh and just remember
it's for your safety if it weren't real
it would be funny huh
[laughter]
it is true uh it's actually it is if you
know you know what because people will
say why are you laughing because if you
know what the Bible is telling you this
is actually laughable it's a joke it's a
joke you know Martin pets we should feel
sorry for these people
in the old days you had Houdini's and
they were contortionists in these days
we have these people and they are
distortionists yeah yeah they distort
everything and the bottom line what
we're trying to show is
that it's a religion it's a religion and
it's active and it's not going away
we've been saying this for three four
five ten years it's not going away this
will be the glue
for the end all right now if there's
only one true religion and that's the
biblical religion
then by definition this must be a false
religion correct
and if it is a false religion would you
want to act upon it would you like to be
sucked into it no no I want to watch it
like a movie and see how it runs itself
against the wall it's not that it's not
going to affect us oh it's going to
affect us oh for sure for sure all of
this will definitely affect it didn't
the test run affect us definitely
you see so the thing is we should not
get sucked into it because it will
affect us but
sucked into it we're gonna get
discouraged all right now if we know
where it's heading and the Bible tells
us where it's heading then we can make
some contingency plans but there will
come a point when we'll be totally
Reliant upon God true
now a few years ago there was a talk at
the United Nations and Rosalind Peterson
addressed the United Nations
and she's actually concerned about
climate change and all of these issues
but she also confirms basically uh some
of the issues that are contributing it
that they deny exactly they that they
put forward as conspiracy theories
correct so you know you have to sift
through of these things and when you and
I would say something like that they
would say conspiracy theory but here it
is being touted at the United Nations
not as a conspiracy but as a fact so
what comes first the horse of the god
we are in a global drumbeat right at the
moment talking about climate change and
global warming
one of the things that is affected by
climate change is agriculture
but some of what we are seeing is
man-made but man-made in a different way
than you may guess
weather modification programs
experimental ones done by private
companies done by the United States
government
uh done by States across the United
States are underway there's more than 50
of them in operation across the United
States
all of these impact agriculture because
they change the microclimates needed for
agriculture to survive
none of these programs that I know of
today and this is all public record are
available at any time with oversight
agricultural oversight or public
oversight
these programs impact Agriculture and
there are programs around the world
international corporations are modifying
our weather all the time and they're
modifying it in ways that cover
thousands and thousands of square miles
most of it is chemically altered so that
what happens is that we are putting
chemicals ground-based chemicals that
are shot into the air or chemicals
coming from airplanes that change and
modify our weather one of the things
that is impacting Crop Production right
now in the United States and reducing
photosynthesis and also impacting the
ability of solar power panels to
generate the type of of power that they
should is persistent jet contrails NASA
talks about persistent jet contrails as
exacerbating global warming because they
trap warmth in the atmosphere when they
produce Cirrus and man-made clouds
NASA also talks about that when we that
these aircraft leaving persistent
contrails are changing our climate
and when they change our climate to the
degree that one jet can leave a
persistent jet contrail which will
spread across our Sky which is a trail
left by a jet
that trail can expand to 4 000
kilometers and lasts for 20 hours
this was unheard of in the early 60s and
the 70s and it wasn't until the late
1980s that there was a change and we
started to have persistent jet contrails
that persist NASA studies show that part
of our global warming problem could be
attributed to these types of contrails
and the Jets that leave them so one of
the issues as we go through
is how do you like your Sky's natural or
man-made and right now we are making
man-made clouds
conspiracy theories Martin or can we say
we told you so let's just leave it at
that people can make their own
conclusions right
so Martin we've come to the conclusion
that we are dealing with a religion
we come to the conclusion
that that religion cannot be a True
Religion yes because there are too many
factors there that tell us that it is a
fake religion
uh now we also have a situation in the
world where moral values that are
encased in the biblical narrative are
under attack
usually so so you have cyber attacks and
you have moral attacks now one of the
moral attacks that is really riling up
conservative thinking parents or
religiously minded parents and people
is the gender issue which all of a
sudden has become a great thing again
Hollywood has prepared the way
and Hollywood has introduced this idea
in their sitcoms in their series that
they produce in their movies that they
produce more and more they snuck it in
and eventually they didn't only sneak it
in they made it the prominent feature
that is true
and every movie that you can imagine
must have at least a scene and then they
put it in subliminally into their
cartoons even for children and you have
all of these things and then they
brought it into the schools they used to
put it in sublimony in cartoons not so
anymore and then they brought it into
the schools and then they they went a
step further and they brought drag shows
into the schools and eventually people
get so riled up that it can almost lead
to a civil war
is that so I think it's not far off all
right now we are thinking about biblical
prophecy and we always say this where is
it heading what is it doing is it going
to make the pendulum swing to the other
side and people say enough we're going
to reinstate
religious values that made this country
great in the past and obviously we're
going down the tube and that for every
country in the world because the same
things have been going on worldwide so
we're going to look at the gender issue
uh we've done it before we've
insinuated many times let's look at some
some real things that are happening
so here you have an article where
parents pull four-year-old from church
school for promoting gender identity
lessons cruel deception now if it was a
normal secular school that would be
something that you might expect but now
it's coming into church schools and that
really gets people upset because they
think the church school should be a safe
haven look if you
um Proclaim that you are a church school
then obviously there must be biblical
teachings that you follow yes and if
those teachings are pretty
straightforward and clear which they are
in Scriptures it takes some theological
gymnastics to rest them from their
context and change it around
for example saying that Paul says if you
burn for one another then get married
and that marriage in according to them
then would include any gender eventually
it might even include other things like
marrying your pet yeah that's actually
ridiculous like they they twist and
fiddle with like Romans completely yes
and that's across the board yeah and
nobody is and when I say nobody I mean
nobody no religious institution is going
to be immune to this kind of attack
so Christian parents in the United
Kingdom pulled their four-year-old son
from the church of England school after
its head teacher allegedly promoted
gender identity lessons
so this is a primary school it planned
to teach young children from a book by
Scott Stewart Title my shadow is Pink
which they felt was inappropriate
according to their legal counsel at the
london-based Christian legal center
well the title itself would be
disturbing
true so let's say that there is a a
reason for the concern
and here's another one National
transgender school shooter possibly
targeted Christians of a hateful
rhetoric senator says
so now it's becoming a hate crime
against Christianity now Christians will
start getting riled up now what what if
in a Flash
it can go so far
that people climb onto the bandwagon
which we said we should first observe
before we climb onto a bandwagon because
we want to know where's the bandwagon
heading
and then we see
they're going to go and enforce the
moral values as they were
and then inadvertently without knowing
they actually enforce papal values
yes and not biblical values
and then a little voice goes up when
finally humanity is Unified on moral
values and it doesn't stay within
Christianity because I'm sure Islam will
climb onto the bandwagon as well and
other religions will climb onto the
bandwagon as well and then they will
unite on something that is common to
them let's bring God back into society
whoever that God is in whatever system
we're talking about
like Rick Warren said it doesn't matter
what makes you do good as long as you do
good as long as you do good how about
giving God some more time how about a
enforced day of rest which they're
talking about and then we will have a
loud cry going out against that which is
which is called the loud cry warning
against the mark of the beast and then
you have everybody finally United and
here is an irritating voice saying that
you are not doing the right thing you're
not working according to the biblical
principle but because all the other
religions are involved and they're happy
to go along with us you're going to be
the Pariah you're going to be the dog in
the story
and eventually instead of the hatred
being focused on everything that is
wrong
couldn't it just turn against that moral
little voice I'm sure that some of these
people that are here being condemned
will add their voice and shout down
those that bring the loud crime
definitely it's the same
the Jews said it's better for one man to
suffer than for the whole nation this
will be it's better that this little
group suffers there's an irritating
little group it's standing in the way of
our moral unity this is very interesting
so the Nashville school shooting should
be investigated as a hit crime since the
transgender shooter intentionally
targeted Christians Senator Josh Hawley
told Fox News on Tuesday the trans
resistance Network a trans activist
group said the transgender shooter felt
no other effective way to be seen than
by killing six people at a private
Presbyterian School
this is fascinating
the Metropolitan Nashville police chief
John Drake said Monday night that some
believe the shooter held resentment for
having to go to that school
because Christian values are an affront
to whatever is contrary to it whatever
that is
this religious attachment
is it heading in a direction it is and
it's so it's the one of the most
Sinister ones
that Satan is coming up with
because like you've just mentioned the
thing is it is immoral but the problem
is this is going to lead to a wrong
outcome okay now it it can become so
pathetic
that they don't want to talk about a
woman anymore they don't want to define
a woman or a female it's now a birthing
parent
and people are looking at this and
they're joking about it because it's so
ridiculous that it deserves to be joked
about
but there's a serious element in it as
well
and I mean if it goes so far that you
even identify as cat and you start
putting litter boxes into schools then
you know if I were there I would
actually use them just to make everybody
clean them up [laughter]
that's a ridiculous thing
but again let's ask the question
Hollywood did they prefigure it yeah
they've always they know what's coming
all right so their Prophet Jesuit
theater
was on the ball and prepared the
mindsets even if it was for a love
that's it they started off you must
remember they started it off with a
laugh and then eventually you mentioned
earlier sitcoms and everything they
started getting more serious with it
till eventually now if you are just
trying to speak against any of this then
you are you are the the Enemy of the
State yeah now Martin this was a Monty
Python movie this is years ago because
John Cleese is very young here
and let's just look at this little
discussion which here here is very
tongue-in-cheek but uh when you look at
the reality today we've moved from a
joke to a reality isn't that so it's
true let's look at it
symbolic of his struggle against reality
well Martin perhaps we should give our
friend in Australia who sent us that
video a little thumbs up it [laughter]
fits in quite well yeah I know it is
well it's actually ridiculous if you
just see how tongue-in-cheek this was
but how it became reality yes absolutely
all right so Martin let's get back to
the serious side of this
not what is happening where's it leading
they must at some stage come a pushback
yes and people must be riled up enough
to become involved in order to achieve
that pushback and it's going to be a
moral issue it's going to be a religious
issue we're going to go back to
religious values we're going to go
pendulum swing let's see
transposing America that's the focus of
tonight's angle
as we just discussed killer Audrey Hale
was living in a sick fantasy world
one that was affirmed and celebrated by
modern culture the fraudulent construct
the boys can become girls and girls can
become boys
in her Twisted mind her mortal enemies
are those who do not affirm her
imaginary identity in this case her old
Christian School and her family
and thus she goes and blows away six
innocent people
including three small children
now the knee-jerk political response
very predictable is to blame the gun
culture urge that AR-15s be banned
but this avoids the undeniable truth
that the left has created a world that
has our young people on a collision
course with reality
media Outlets which are supposed to be
interested in actual effects are oddly
subdued about the prospect of learning
more about the Killer's motives
now we have no idea what was in Ms
Hale's mind why she targeted the
Covenant School but it is clear that if
this is a case of anti-christian hate we
all should know all about it including
how it was inspired unstable people are
especially susceptible to poisonous
ideology we already know that some of
the less radical Fringe groups are
viciously anti-christian
now look at how they attack churches and
pro-life centers over the last few years
and there's a trans day of Vengeance
planned for this Saturday
menacing videos are being posted online
to promote it
now not a peep about this from the doj
of course and this week Merrick Garland
refused to address even a possible hate
crimes angle in this Nashville shooting
do you plan on opening a hate crime
investigation
for the targeting of Christians
the FBI and ATF are both on the scene
working with the local police as of now
a motive hasn't been identified
this is about politics pure and simple
now Democrats have invested a lot in the
storyline that white American Christians
are the most dangerous people on the
face of the planet
remember that group they're the real
enemies you have these young people
who've organized online who call
themselves America First really I view
that as a slogan as a way to say we are
white nationalists Christian
nationalists believe the United States
was established as an explicitly white
Christian Nation and any threat to their
agenda must be stamped out even if that
means violence if you're talking about
people who uh believe in in ethno state
or of a religious
um theocracy
we are indeed at a Tipping Point I know
a lot of people say that but we're at it
we have no time to argue about the
obvious or deny basic facts or pretend
we're living in a fantasy world where
you know one sex can become another sex
we can't allow charlatans to divide us
hard work Family Faith and patriotism is
what will save us they always have
modern her final words sum up our entire
position that's exactly so you can look
at all of this and you can Scott you can
everything gets riled up in you because
of all of this
but then you should listen to what she
said last and this is what our position
has been the whole time this is our
position where is it heading we're going
to have a pendulum swing so just to make
clear we're not agreeing with what she
said in the end
we just saying that this is going to
swing the pendulum because patriotism
and all of this is going to lead to the
demise of somebody else yes
and that is what we're saying this is
proving that the pendulum is going to
swing
I'm not going to disagree with you
but I'm going to say
that we're not against
setting right moral issues no that's the
thing yeah so so even Church
organizations would say finally at last
you know moral issues are being
addressed and humanity is moving in the
right direction
but again let's reiterate if there is an
injection of poison in the moral campus
then it's going to lead to Perdition yes
and there is an injection of poison in
the moral campus because it is following
changed rules and the Bible clearly says
here are they that keep the Commandments
of God and hold to the testimony and
those that keep the Commandments and
have the faith of Jesus
so this will come into Clash so the
final Clash will be between two
religious systems
and the whole world will be involved now
who could write so brilliant a script
we're watching a movie right that's for
sure and we're asking ourselves who can
write so brilliant a script only the
devil can achieve that because even the
actors don't know what's going on that's
the thing so most of the people even
the news anchor
is probably sucked in yes and is caught
up in this and we agree it is ludicrous
of what all this immorality and he's got
it covered at every base he's created
over the time this interposition
this ain't Shoup as I said he has
created all of these religious systems
that have been warring against each
other for how knows how long
now he's got them to the point where
they are unified and building joint
centers and abrahamic religion and
signing documents and the man in white
is very busy and he's the one running
the man in white behind the scenes
Jesuit Theater Hollywood and then
between all of this now he's addressing
all of these issues and now you can't
say excuse me you have to separate from
that religion because it's not in
harmony with the Bible because you've
just got them all together and if
somebody talks against this they're
going to be the enemy and now you have
the moral issue coming right and
somebody wants to say excuse me there's
something wrong these people are going
to get very riled up
can you see the time of trouble coming
it's already it's already on the
precipice so modern are they already
asking for legislation
to correct the moral compass yes let's
just look at this one Newsmax Tennessee
house advances Bill criminalizing drag
shows we don't have to go into the
details of this one they're already
proposing legal action and laws to
combat it yes it must go in a direction
it will go in the direction that's for
sure so the transgender agenda
will shake Humanity it
is shaking Humanity
I want to predict it's going to shake
every single denomination and ease
already shaking every single
denomination we have to make sure that
we know our Bibles
that we know what God wants and that our
life comes into harmony with his will
for sure and there are many Sins Not
Just
sins against the seventh commandment
there are Ten Commandments and they're
very broad they cover every aspect of
humanity we have to examine ourselves on
every single one of them whether we are
in harmony with God or not and if there
is a is a transgression in terms of the
sixth commandment in your mind
or the 8th or the ninth or the 10th
commandment or the first the second the
third the fourth the fifth
then you have to get our lives into
harmony with God exactly including
anything that's wrong in the seventh yes
yes you can't exclude that one and say
you were born that way no no he created
you male and female
so a little light Studio put together a
very interesting one of which we take a
few excerpts and just see what they came
up with
transgendered bathrooms have come out of
nowhere the next stop on this train is
pedophilia I guarantee it
guaranteed in fact he guarantees it so
much he will commit pedophilia just to
make sure that this happens
I mean the guy is an absolute a
legendary I guarantee you
pedophilia is next
Dr James Cantor of Cam H I recall in an
interview with the Toronto Star said
[music] uh refer to pedophilia as a
sexual orientation like every other
sexual orientation pedophilia
can have different characteristic anyone
could be born a pedophile we should
accept that pedophiles
are people who have not chosen their
sexuality should accept that pedophilia
is a sexual preference statistics
indicate that there will be one or two
of you who are struggling with some form
of pedophilic interest but the problem
is these people can't talk about their
feelings because they know that they
will be hated for it
however it doesn't make sense and that's
because we're talking about biology
we're talking about a sexual orientation
if you want to be a drag queen and your
parents don't let you you need new
parents are there children inside oh
yeah there's three or four of them so
but these girls are all fully closed
this is a PG performance like it's hor
it's family friendly
actually one doesn't even want to show
it but just to make people realize that
we're not dealing with figments of the
imagination but with realities
it's a very sick World we're living in
and no wonder God put a limit
to the interpolition to time which is
called time exactly now just that alone
Martin doesn't it tell you that time is
running out
didn't God have to
make an end to it once before yes modern
ones actually more than once okay
now imagine if the the transgender
movement
is riling up Christians don't the
Christians need a champion yes they need
the hero that will come and sort this
all out all right now if I may guess or
why why me why don't you guess who Could
That hero be maybe the pope isn't the
wound going to be healed isn't the whole
world going to wander after him so I
wonder what his position would be what
do you think his position would be he
will be against it and then sometimes
allow it yeah he speaks some obscure
language double talk but for the sake of
attracting the masses to him yes he
would have to speak against it right to
swing the pendulum to swing the pendulum
let's see what he says
so agenda ideology is one of the most
dangerous ideological colonizations his
comments Echo previous statements
condemning transgender ideology as a
fundamental disorder being forced on the
youth
do you think that'll go down well with
the Christians yes very good okay
because
no but it won't go off well with those
people that were mentioning it as a
sexual orientation no it won't go down
well with them at all
he made these comments during an
interview with an Argentinian newspaper
and uh he was asked why is it dangerous
he continued
because it blurs differences and the
value of men and women all humanity is
the tension of differences
it is to grow through the tension of
differences the pope said the question
of gender is diluting the differences
and making the world the same all dull
all alike and that is contrary to human
vocation
so he's saying the right words but in
the same breath he speaks well or
condones certain actions which are
clearly anti-biblical yes
so without laboring the point there must
be constant media efforts to drive the
point
to irritate those that want to take a
stand
and one of them is this UK woman
who was arrested for silently praying
she was arrested for what was in her
mind and then she was released and then
she was arrested again that must rile up
the people yeah I'm sure especially when
you add a judge
setting a free
all right so the next point is a high
school football coach was fired for
prayer
that he did and so he went to court and
he won the court case yes so these are
issues that are constantly coming out in
the media reminding people that there is
a war against religious values and
people are getting riled up
isn't that going to make the pendulum
swing it's starting it's really starting
the next thing you have is sports stars
and there are many of them here's one
goaltender James Reimer who refused to
wear a pride Jersey and they will say
wonderful and many will be riled up and
that trying to bring people to climb
onto this bandwagon this train that is
picking up speed and almost like that
other guy said doesn't have any breaks
it doesn't have any brakes now you
remember that in the spirit of Prophecy
there was this dream of the train that
was picking up speed
and that the the captain yeah in the
front the conductor yeah and the one
controlling the steam engine was Satan
himself
sir Martin
people are beginning to stand up
and they're saying I'm not going along
with this agenda and they will get
followers
and then the pendulum will start
swinging
and once that pendulum swings
and a little group stands up and says we
are in accord with your values but
there's a problem
and then you point out the problem
transgression
of God's law
following the Beast yes and his values
rather than the moral dictates of of God
here are they that keep the Commandments
of God hold to the testimony of Jesus
there will be an irritation
and eventually all that anger
will be swung and directed at that small
group yeah
so Martin may God help us as we face
this
certain future
together I mean let's pray
Heavenly Father
the world is on an Express train to
Perdition
and help us Lord to focus on why you
have
given the last message of warning in
Revelation
to people
so that they may present it to the world
so that eyes may be open
now we know Lord that in the loud cry
many will respond
and sadly many of those will take the
place of those that leave the ranks of
those that should know better
who have allowed ideologies to
infiltrate into their own minds
please help us to be effective in
bringing the Lost message of warning to
the world
and make us part of the loud cries our
prayer in Jesus name amen amen
foreign